hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition Melina masters I believe
that the fastest and most effective way
to grow a business is to model the
strategies of people who have already
done what you're trying to do so today
we're going to look at how a
stay-at-home mom was frustrated about
educating her child and not having
enough products to help them created her
own simple video and ended up helping
build a billion-dollar business this is
a story of Baby Einstein found their
Julie anger Clark and a top three
lessons you can learn from her success
Julie anger Clark is an American
entrepreneur that developed the Baby
Einstein video series for children she
grew up in Michigan and with the
Michigan State University where she
majored in the humanities right at a
school in her cart began teaching
English to high school students she was
enjoying her new profession and her
ability to help shape and educate young
minds when something happened that would
change the course of her life forever
after a new Clark had her first daughter
she became fascinated by the latest
research dealing with newborns and their
capacity to learn she began the search
baby stores far and wide for material
that was both educational and
appropriate for her her child's
development while still being fun at the
end of research in your Clark had come
up empty-handed so she began to think
about creating her own products she
thought that if she couldn't find what
she was looking for in stores maybe
other mothers were in the same situation
being a busy mother that she was however
she didn't act on her idea until a full
year later along with her husband and
her Clark borrowed a friend's video
camera and headed into her basement to
film or would become the very first of
many Baby Einstein videos with her baby
as the live audience her cat as a prop
and her husband as a geographer the pair
set out to create their vision turned
down by many retailers Rainer Clark
decided to hit the floors of toy trade
shows to get the word out about her
product still she found it difficult to
find people who shared her enthusiasm
finally however in your Clark was able
to convince a buyer from the right stuff
a high-end toy retailer to stock a few
trial copies of her video for their
stores when they sold out within three
days the right stuff agreed to sign an
exclusive deal with in your Clark baby
Einstein videos were now being
distributed in 34 stores across the
country and selling out fast
today the baby Einstein is being
produced by Disney and total revenues
are over 1
billion dollars annually
by tapping into a major frustration and
by helping other people solve it a new
Clarke was able to go from stay-at-home
mom to ultra successful entrepreneur to
help you take your company to the next
level here are three action items you
can learn from Julianne or Clarke
action item number one look for a need
some of the most successful businesses
in the world have been built around
solving personal frustrations if you're
looking to start a new business a great
place to start is to think about the
biggest frustrations that you've had in
your life and how you solved them if
it's big and painful enough chances are
other people have the same problems and
would pay you to solve it for them Anna
Clark had never been a videographer nor
had she had any previous interest in
starting our own company she was a
stay-at-home mom and it was a role she
loved she enjoyed spending time with her
newborn baby and was more than happy to
give up her full-time job to do so and
when it came to being a mother and her
Clark took her duties very seriously the
idea behind what would become a new
Clarks billion-dollar baby was born from
a need a simple need that had been right
under her nose she wanted a learning
tool for a new child and when she
couldn't find what you wanted on the
market she decided to create her own
inner Clark stuck to what she knew best
babies she didn't spend countless hours
in search of a business idea the
business idea found her and it was
because a new Clark had kept her eyes
open to such an opportunity that she was
able to seize it when it came along
according to a new Clark believe it or
not when I stopped working when I was
six months pregnant I had no intention
of going back to work when my daughter
was born I started taking her to museums
and places like that but it wasn't very
engaging to her or to me I knew my baby
I knew what she liked to look at I
assumed that what my baby like to look
at most other babies would too the first
Baby Einstein video took off because it
was completely new concept it was an
entirely new idea no one else had done
videos for babies
action memo number two spread the word
you can have the greatest product or
service in the world but it won't take
off unless you tell people about it make
sure the value that you provide is so
incredible that people can't help but
talk about you to their friends and
family word-of-mouth marketing is highly
effective and extremely cheap but you
have to give them something to talk
about so just how exactly did her
basement operation become the billion
dollar industry leader that it is today
what it all came down to she says was
her ability to hit the streets and get
people talking about her business when
the first Baby Einstein video came out a
new Clark could not find any takers for
it took a more than a year to come up
with an idea on how to do that but
finally a new Clark knew what she had to
do she packed up and headed to New York
City for the American International Toy
Fair she was determined to get one of
the buyers from the right start a
high-end bebe retailer to take notice of
her video after that the man for Baby
Einstein products exploded according to
a new Clark I knew if I could get it
into the hands of a mom or an executive
who had a baby that would sell it I ran
up to them and said you're going to love
this video you have to watch it it's
perfect for your store there was a
reporter from People magazine who loved
it and wrote a piece on it
there was a producer on Oprah that also
loved it and they put it into a segment
parenting magazine also named Baby
Einstein video of the year at the end of
the day word of mouth is your most
important means to get the word out and
we have a great group mothers
number three build a brand when you're
creating your business pay close
attention to your messaging and how you
want the world to know you if you can
articulate your message in a clear and
unique way it not only helps people
understand what is that you do and if
it's for them it also helps them tell
other people as well if people can't
remember what you do and why you're
special they can't tell their friends
about you what parent wouldn't want
their kids who grew up to be the next
Albert Einstein for the company's name
to the rest of its promotional strategy
in your clark created and implemented a
brilliant branding strategy that helped
her innovative concept achieve the
success that it did Einstein might not
have watched playful videos with puppets
as a child but that hasn't stopped
thousands of parents and buying the Baby
Einstein series in the hopes that the
videos will aid in the development of
their children
none of the company's promotional
literature was ever still bold as to
claim that their products were
specifically engineered to make babies
smarter but with a name like Baby
Einstein the powers of association leave
little up the chance a new Clark was
saying the things parents wanted to hear
and making a product's parents thought
the kids needed to see and some circles
any parent who was not showing their
kids be behind some videos was even seen
as a bad parent that was a true mark of
success of a new Clarks branding
strategy according to a new Clark
everyone asked how did you come up with
the name the truth is I just sat down
and thought of it we didn't test market
or anything I believe the name of our
company was incredibly important to our
success when I first created it I didn't
think I was creating the company just a
name of a video however the debate the
name Baby Einstein caught on very fast
and became the generic name for baby
videos it seemed like our timing was
perfect
so remember look for a need spread the
word and build a brand to finish up this
video I wanted to share with my favorite
true stories about Julian Urquhart and
some of her best inspirational quotes
Julianna Clark fired up the TEDx Detroit
conference in Michigan in September 2011
by telling her remarkable story the
story began with her discovering that
she had stage four cancer and ended
tearfully with her telling how she
helped build a billion-dollar business
while working at home in her pajamas
inner Clarke told the audience all the
important work I've done in my life I've
done in my pajamas her inspiring story
brought tears everyone's eyes but part
of the keynote address was a nur
Clarke's lecture on the importance of
self confidence which she claimed helped
her build the Baby Einstein video series
and battle against breast cancer
a nur clerk told the crowd how you must
believe in yourself even if no one else
does a powerful recovery from cancer her
creation of a billion-dollar business
and her ability to raise three children
are all attributed to her belief that
anyone can do it as long as they have
self-confidence
you
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the masters if you
liked the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below or
leave a comment it makes me want to do
more these videos for you guys I'd also
love to hear what you have to think if
you have any questions if you leave if
you want to leave a comment under the
video so thank you and we'll see you in
the next episode